hello everybody and welcome to the lobby
i'm your host chris waters standing in
for daniel dwyer who off vacation but
still around the world he is at gamescom
and we're going to be talking a lot
about gamescom shortly but first i want
to remind you guys we are giving away a
playstation 4. all you got to do is
tweet at gamespot using the hashtag
greatestgamingmoment and when tell us
what your greatest gaming moment is
we'll be taking a look at some of those
tweets and picking the winner by the end
of the show so get them in there uh but
before we get to gamescom's stuff and
giving away that ps4 let's talk about
call of duty advanced warfare there's a
huge multiplayer reveal event last week
dan reichert from giantbomb was there
rob handler from gamespot was there i
was my first man from giant i was on
vacation you were on vacation i saw the
game at e3 though some i'm familiar
familiar with it with the details exo
jumping yeah business all right well
let's talk about it because
this is call of duty multiplayer i think
jeff you probably have more call of duty
multiplayer experience than all of us on
the count here combined
dan do you play much yeah i've kind of
been the call of duty guy for the last
like several years well that's right
because at game informer you said you
did the cover story for it right the
cover story for advanced warfare and
goes and i did all the review and like
multiplayer trips and all that stuff so
yeah so you guys got chops rob i played
a lot um of the you know the first
couple and then kind of dropped off on
ghosts played like a couple hours well
advanced warfare of course the big thing
is movement is you got like a double
jump you can do this like dash to the
side business and uh what what's i think
it's pretty freaking great like i think
it is just this like really neat kinetic
change up to the way those matches play
what do you guys think i i like how it
had the basic stuff you can do like the
dashes the dodges and things like that
but you can also go into your
customization and pick that like extra
xo ability whether it's the mid-air
hover or you know the boost slam thing
where you punch down on the ground with
that finite battery so you know you
basically have to pick and choose when
to use that so are the the
soldiers as resilient as they always
have been like they just go down in a
few shots because that's that kind of
ground pound thing seems like you would
just get shot out of the air over and
over again it'd have to be real fast
right yeah i haven't actually seen the
ground i feel like it's not something
you want to do when you're it's facing
off with someone you're not going to
like double jump and try to ground power
it's just going to be like a almost like
a stealth thing like you got up behind
somebody and you're like check this out
bam yeah
you're up above someone yeah just jump
down on them and punch and because it's
so easy to get to different levels of
the map now with the double jump yeah
you know yeah the mobility is huge and
and it's one of those things where you
know it's like call of duty has been so
just
stayed and plain for for years and years
that
you know
at least they're finally making basic
changes to just mobility and stuff like
that that could be huge so yeah i came
away from my time with it going like
this could be cool yeah as opposed to
you know adding up you know what more
dogs i mean they were they kept they
kept trying to top themselves and i felt
like now that you know they eliminated
like death streaks
just basic score streaks now but um
going back on dashing the coolest thing
was like
remember one of the last matches we
played i was kind of finally kind of
like synapses my brain were hitting it
was like guy on a platform walking um
above me how do i get to him jump up and
then left and then chalk on the face
like it was just immediate gratification
where like once that's in the mix you
can have some really interesting
gameplay
yeah and it seems like you know it's i
think there are some people that are
quick to just go like oh looks like
titanfall it's like yeah it does but
like the
the exo suits are it's not mobile the
same way titanfall is and and like
there's certainly some similarities
there but i i think it they're carving
out their own thing it's a different
kind of mobility right with titanfall
you need to kind of you have the double
jump right but you have to in order to
make the most of titanfall you're
running along walls yeah you're doing
wall hops and all this like really cool
parkour stuff that i really love um
this is you know this is different this
seems like a slightly more deliberate
than that where it is that kind of just
like double jump boost left like it's
almost like ut or something with the
kind of double tap dashes and that sort
of stuff yeah with those jukes yeah it
feels like there's more weight to them
than there is in titanfall titanfall is
kind of i don't want to say floaty but i
mean you can really just be sprinting
around doing all the wall jump to wall
jump stuff and like this yeah the liver
is probably a good word for it so you
can dodge something or get out of the
way of a grenade or something but you're
not just you know flying all over the
map and i think because of that the
short range boost and it's you know the
hover is you know it's a short range
hover you're not going to like be
hovering around the map like it's some
kind of drone guy raining down death
upon everybody but it's all sort of
focused on this
short-term maneuverability this like
just a quick move a quick sort of
engagement and i think that the way that
call of duty's always been is
firefights are very quick it's all about
it's about positioning and then you know
once you guys are actually shooting at
each other it's almost it's over like
almost immediately after that so having
that stuff crammed into that sort of
that speed
is you know i think really interesting
that seems like a difficult thing too
you know it's it'll lead to situations
where you go like well you know i could
just pull the trigger because i know
that works but maybe in some cases a
side dash
would be you know a smarter idea
assuming you can then reposition it like
i might actually be able to faster than
that get out of the way of someone
shooting at me yeah as opposed to just
oh the first bullet hit me uh i'm dead
yeah yeah
because the next two are going to hit
before i can react and move
significantly if you can actually dash
then it sort of stretches out that
encounter maybe yeah
it's kind of smart the way they map it
to the controller because you know
clicking the left stick has always been
sprint forward but it doesn't really do
anything if you're going left and right
or back and now i mean it's just
basically click is the extra speed in
whatever direction you're holding the
left stick so that makes a lot of sense
yeah i'm really curious to see like down
the road like
like when we were playing not many
people were using that it was only the
last couple of matches where like oh i
finally like pulled that off
successfully in the trailer that i just
saw you get comfortable with it yeah and
once that starts happening
i really see that game looking a lot
different and just feeling a lot
different like you know instead of just
like head shots it's gonna be like oh
that combo move he just pulled like
that's gonna be something to look
forward to and i think especially in
uplink mode which is the new sort of
mode that they were showing off the
event we went to it's uh you know
there's a neutral ball that you have to
throw into this glowing sphere on either
end of the map uh
the fact that you know those juke
maneuvers that maneuverability when
you're trying to run the ball from point
a to b
you know that opens up a whole different
kind of pace it feels like an american
gladiators event it kind of does like
you get extra points if you like dunk it
through by boosting through yeah yeah i
like that a lot
for me though the the mode conversation
just starts and stops with like did they
put headquarters in it or not because
that's you know like ghost didn't have
it it was like why why would you not do
that headquarters is your jam it's kind
of the other mode it's like there's team
death match and there's headquarters and
then you're done there's there's other
domination it's all right oh that's
great like it's domination is like older
than me at this point it's just like
come on team deathmatch is the mode
that's that's the the mode that lasts
and then you know headquarters was kind
of the young upstart that was fun but oh
you know there's hardpoint that's coming
on back okay yeah hardpoint's good too
yeah we even touched briefly on uplink
how
you could i mean especially with you
know all this customization of class and
everything like that but we were almost
getting a conversation about like like a
football team like different actual type
of people customized for different
things like you know running of the ball
he would be decked out with the you know
double xo abilities just because that's
always doing it he's running you know
the run running boost and then maybe
like a health regenerate like and then
you got maybe like a qb throwing it down
field like that's all they're doing like
you could
basically see a team coming kind of i
think that's how it differentiates
itself from modes like oddball and other
sort of control the ball stuff that
we've seen before it's you can do this
pass and i didn't notice this until we
were going back and looking at the
footage but
if you have the ball and you're running
and any of your teammates get into your
view it'll like auto select one of them
as a pass target and then you just pull
the left trigger and gun it to them yeah
do you realistically think anyone's
gonna actually care about that mode uh i
wanna do it yeah i mean like like beyond
like i wanna do it and then like play it
for
the first week
i feel like if you look at you know call
of duty modes and you look at the like
the player counts we are just talking
about tdm and death and domination oh
for sure and that's like normally what i
play yeah
that's i can see getting as much
traction as like you know gun game and
some of those added like you know one of
the chamber modes that treyarch's put in
the black there's the one you want to
play when you don't just want to go play
the bread yeah yeah exactly yeah and
it's not going to get the numbers that
tdm gets or whatever but like people
play it it's one of those hard things
where it's like you know i feel like you
know there's this expectation that they
need to keep coming up with new things
and also other stuff but ultimately
people are just going to play those two
modes so is this a new i mean the the
movement of call of duty you're
optimistic about the future do you think
this will be uh i mean certainly it
seems like we're all welcoming it do you
think that the consuming public buying
millions of call of duty copies a year i
think it's really it is it is definitely
risky on their part because if you look
at you know kind of it almost feels like
they've been afraid to make drastic
changes to call of duty because they're
not broke because they're golden goose
yeah you know like if you if you mess
with it too much you know it's no longer
the game that people fell in love with
but i think they've reached a point now
i mean you look at ghosts you look at
kind of just the the player numbers and
stuff like that it didn't seem like it
had the staying power like they
obviously need to make changes yeah and
and personally as someone who's just
been you know getting like more and more
bored with it as the years go on like
this is
uh the most dramatic change they've yeah
you know it's not just like hey we came
up with a ninth new way to unlock stuff
um though they came up with that too
they definitely yeah
there's a pick 13 now jack it's a whole
different game
whoa and then loot crates right because
battlefield yeah everyone's favorite
battlefield mass effect listen man they
just bring that they gotta bring micro
transactions in there you think they
will because that's always been the
thing they're like call of duty made so
much money that they always were like
uh we don't need to sell currency or or
you know we don't need to charge for
multiplayer they tried with elite i mean
yeah yeah they did it right and then you
know obviously they sold this snoop dogg
voice pack which is fantastic i use it
whenever i'm playing call of duty ghosts
i use the snoop dogg voice
nailed it
and yeah so it's like one of those
things where like you look at the loot
crates you look at it like oh how it was
a mass effect 3 and you're like oh am i
going to start like start buying crates
right so unlock channels there and they
get something neat who knows you may be
paying for little things in call of duty
addition to the big but they've been
weapon skins and all this other crap for
a long time like you know for the last
couple of years they've you know they've
been getting into selling you garbage uh
so why not new innovative ways yeah to
tell you guys that's right this weapon
skin that you'll barely see on your gun
because you're who looks at that because
you're sprinting it looks like weed
leaves
yay
all right finally all right all right
call of duty advanced warfare uh it's
out in like a few months so if you know
a lot about it probably see a little bit
more uh before it comes out but let's
talk gamescom now because in the past 24
hours we had a microsoft press
conference a sony press conference uh
big to-do's over there in germany if you
watched we had them live on the site as
well as a live blog and a bunch of uh
articles related to them if you want to
read more on those about stuff we're
going to talk about now so just listen
like reading is done man come on what's
up we're talking about it here let's
talk about microsoft's press conference
uh did you guys do you guys wake up too
early in your life to watch absolutely
so you've read about you've heard about
it presumably one of things you've heard
about rise of to the tomb raider is
let's see if i can word this right uh
holiday 2015 exclusively on xbox yeah
right yeah so hey that's big that that's
exclusively on xbox but for what period
of time is the big question right how
much value does that have uh well it's a
holiday season so you know they're
asking you know they're asking people
that if you want it for christmas this
year this is the one platform you can
get it on or two you know because they
said exclusively on xbox
they didn't maybe there could be a 360
version you'd like to think that at some
point they'll stop making xbox 360 games
and start making them for the new
platforms instead of these like these
old dinosaurs yeah like straddling the
line and making no one happy
um yeah it's you know i feel like you
know hey this this is just like do you
want to play rise of the tomb raider
definitive edition
ps4 then mid 2016. yeah pc
25x deluxe yeah there's plenty of people
that don't want to wait that long i mean
i know that i like the first one quite a
bit and oh yeah yeah i'll just buy it on
xbox so i think it's a pretty good get
for them yeah is it a system seller does
it tip the needle i don't think it's
that like killer app or anything like
that but it was a really good game that
lasted every little bit helps when it
comes to that stuff you know it's like
sony did their destiny stuff and you
know it's like it's everyone's got their
own little bits here a little first on
but this is i mean this is a major
sequel in a major franchise uh you know
it's certainly bigger than like you got
some better pauldrons in diablo if
you've got the playstation version or
whatever it's your last of us clickers
that you can fight as opposed to right
yeah yeah so you know it's that's that's
a big deal uh i don't know it's hard for
me to like get too
built up about it because i just didn't
get into that last tomb raider game oh
he didn't much so i'm with dan that
thing was awesome it was awesome and
then the ending
kind of just turned me is it because you
guys are creeps and you're all you
bought into the whole thing of like yeah
they want they want you to want to
protect laura
i actually like islands
because i like you do the environmental
deaths and then
oh god i actually really don't want to
die they do a good job with those things
yeah between that and like that in dead
space i think does the best just jarring
like oh god that's terrible that's
happened
i think we're like into snuff films now
dance
yeah and we'll talk about that off
camera but cool yeah that's a bonus
segment so there you go the sequel to
eight millimeters
machine kill them all oh god what dark
dark uh speaking of exclusive xbox one
we gotta look at quantum breaks some new
we saw the gameplay basically for the
first time
and hey it's a third person shooter
finally can i hide behind stuff
yes great wait but there needs to be
more than me just popping dudes in the
head is there some kind of weird
mechanic that involves that like uh
polygonal time fractalization thing if i
miss a head shot can i roll it back to
get it right the next time what about a
confusing tv show that no one seems to
know how it works
yes no we're not even going to talk
about that this time around yeah you
just you get to pop dudes no it's good
that they're finally showing this as a
game i know like when they when they
shut down that la studio people were
like what does this mean for quantum
break and they're like nothing don't
worry cool it's fine it's fine it's fine
it's gonna be a game um yeah so you know
it's like it's the next game from these
guys and that's that's exciting they've
done some some amazing work so hopefully
this will pan out i mean i think it
looks nice but yeah at some point if
you're like yeah by the way all this
works going into a cover shooter yeah
yeah i mean we all said alan wake had
its sort of shooting mechanics
wasn't with the flashlight and you know
there's so is this you know is the the
stuff we see here in a little bit is it
that is that going to be a a gimmick
that's interesting that like strings you
between the in the the like more
compelling narrative connections or
mysteries uh
i don't know tentatively excited about
it because i think it's a nice looking
game but you know like it's kind of too
early to tell did you like ellen wake
not especially
so that's why i'm kind of hesitant on
this one
yeah i think we're gonna see some weird
stuff happening here but the rest of the
microsoft press conference i don't know
if you hide behind something to shoot
people you're right that is weird
no but jeff the the cans are moving you
see
and then he's running away from a
grenade uh because basically at any time
he runs is the time
time seems kind of right you've got this
little like yellow line in the corner
depleting whenever he does that kind of
thing yeah i mean you know the time
you know i never want to run out of that
time rewinded potion yeah as long as i
can use that yeah as long as we can talk
about what soulja boy said about braid
for another couple of years
uh then yes please give me more time
more games there's no point to this game
you just you just shoot yeah and then
you're right side that's right it's like
mario for people who like to get high as
you said yeah yeah this is like uh gears
of war for people who like to get high i
thought gears of war was figures of war
for people like to get high well you
know it's a big demographic there's a
lot of there's a lot of there that's
denver it's illegal the rest of uh
microsoft's press conference i mean they
talked a lot they did kind of the
what i think of as the sony thing
beating that indie drum that id8 xbox
thing saying we've got you know space
engineers goat simulator all coming
first on xbox one uh did you guys get
any general impressions of how the you
know totally how the conference went how
it worked out for microsoft what their
message was i think you know i think
they got some stuff that got people
talking you know they they also got out
there and talked about you know it's
like nothing you would get up on stage
and get all sexy about but like the dlna
support for media playback and you know
kind of getting that stuff on the box
finally they'll put out a codec list
that actually supports all the codecs
you'd want it to support unlike the 360
which didn't so maybe less transcoding
for people in the future very exciting i
heard you just said
see video files okay all right i know
what those is you need to download the
real player and install that and you can
watch real video files get it right that
yellow exactly it's right there let's
just just get closer
it's fine fantastic sony now let's talk
about that one i i did get to watch the
mostly the entirety of they rolled a
bunch of trailers yeah yeah some of the
parts that broke yep yeah there was some
broken parts
at least the camera work was a little
steadier this year last year's like whoa
devil may care attitude uh
one of the highlights for me was like
during that you know the weird talky
part where they just talk about features
and don't show cool stuff but actually
some of the features are kind of cool
playstation now playstation tv blah blah
blah yeah the share play was sort of the
one they talked about i think they kind
of announced it yeah it was one of the
kind of initial things they talked about
with the console and then it wasn't it
was one of the many features that
weren't there at launch even though they
talked about it so they're kind of
getting ready to make good on that so as
i understand it it's uh local games that
you can play local co-op like you and a
buddy on the couch
if you can play those online with like
if dan and i want to play child of light
together and i'm you know the the
princess adventuring around and you're
my little igniculus firefly buddy if you
do if you don't have the game
we can just we can connect online you
can play as that dude in my game okay so
i read that straight from a sony blog
post okay
okay i think that you know the other
thing is that this will be kind of like
past the controller type stuff when they
talked about this feature originally it
was the idea of like you're at a spot in
a game you're stuck and you can hand
control of the game over to someone else
and they can get past that spot for you
so this
sounds like it will be using something
similar to playstation now like a video
streaming because they're saying you
know the person doesn't need to own the
game right so you know it'd be like you
know over a video stream you'll be able
to
invite them to take control via video
and play the game for a while and then
that'll also theoretically work for
games that you want to play local co-op
in
that's where it gets a little shaky for
me because it's like well developers
couldn't be bothered to do the work to
make it online for realsies huh right
here you go why make it online but it's
specifically there for people that don't
own the game so it could be like you
know if my sister's having a really
tough time with the boss fight in the
game you know she could have me just
kind of dial in i guess and take over
for a little bit yeah i wonder how that
works of signing in and trophies and
things like that like if you're
controlling someone else's game if that
i don't know you get the the puppet
master trophy for you know helped out
help someone through it
but the other example they gave was uh
tower fall ascension uh which and they
the example was specifically like
cooperatively take on a challenge quest
right so i've got towerfall i want to
beat this quest jeff comes in to help me
out but tower fall ascension is a local
competitive game as well so like can you
and i also just duel i'm going to say
probably i i my what i took away from
the press conference and just kind of
talking about that feature
you know over time as they've kind of
talked about it and not talked about it
is that yeah it is just kind of we can
just jump in and play whatever we want
because it'll be basically kind of i
think the theory is that it'll be just
translating controller inputs that are
coming in over the network to controller
inputs that would be happening locally
yeah so uh so at some point
you start to actually extrapolate that
out and think about consumer grade
broadband connections and bandwidth
concerns and stuff like that like
playstation now is running on gigantic
insane servers and
you know is is not
just like you were there
all the time yeah and you know on live
and certainly stuff like that and doing
a towerfall ascension versus like an nba
2k
yeah and you you think about towerfall
ascension and the reason why it doesn't
have online multiplayer is kind of
two-fold of it being a small team that
might not be able to make that work
happen but also like that theory of like
you know
the latency is too much yeah you need
that
sharpness imagine taking that latency
and then adding to it an entire entire
video stream that doesn't sound like
it'd be a fun experience i don't know so
i i feel like that's going to be one of
those things that will work better for
some games than others and and who knows
how they'll
like
compensate for some of that stuff or
even like for
far cry 4 how they what was that whole
thing with the with the 10 keys yeah so
they announced that back at e3 they did
and then they said what only two hours
then yeah so back at e3 they did say it
was like a time limited thing so yeah
you'll be able to invite up to 10 people
separately
to download some version of the game
uh and then
they'll be able to play with you for two
hours that to me just seems like a
pre-order thing waiting to happen i'm
just like hey convert this download you
already downloaded it into the real
thing yep
i think two hours of playing co-op is a
good amount of time to decide whether or
not you like a game enough to drop 60
bucks yeah so yeah i think it's really
smart uh what did you guys think about
the cardboard box showing that was a
great gear
situation
that was absurd so stupid so great i
love it it's just like hey you know we
talked about the cardboard box before
but look man we really want to get into
the nuances we told you everything about
this cardboard just a box we also
put a pin up on it and our sold the
soldiers you go up against are like
what's so hard up that they are like i
a picture of a sexy lady over here i
gotta run up on it yeah looney tunes all
over again that's great
if you think about it that's been the mo
of metal gear for some time now with the
horn magazines dropping the other weird
stuff they've done or over time the the
soldiers are
horn dogs and it's crazy
idiots
i like that they have added a bunch of
features to the cardboard box i guess
why not like cardboard
i love that i love that it is stupid but
but also trying to be super serious
right yeah and then it's just like this
weird preachy
you know war tale
and then here i am hiding in a cardboard
box
real time 24-hour day cycle like at some
point yeah cardboard exactly someone
needs to just say save kojima from
himself god
there's a later one where the box is on
the ground he just crawls out the side
yeah the dude yeah i think that's this
one here yeah he's got very peripheral
vision well he's distracted there's a
sexy lady on it oh my goodness
she's in a bed of flowers yeah
i also love how much someone really
thought about that like different you
know it's like an origami box like
different artwork on different folds
yeah like how it's 1984 and he's got a
ps4 box on his head i like everything
that's got to be just for the trailer
that's that's probably i wouldn't put a
pass on it
yeah the metal gear is really stupid it
always has been that's something it's
been stupid in ways that like make me
super angry at times but sometimes it's
stupid in the exact right way i mean
that's that's closer to the exact right
way they had issues of game informer and
metal gear three which was set in the
60s so they could have a ps4 box on his
head in 1984 so it could be canon in the
stupid stupid world of metal gear ugh
the best lore all right last game i want
to talk about out of the sony press
conference they finished it up uh
michelle on sales new team wild sheep
this game wild uh which
just basically showed a bunch of people
running around and then a bunch of
animals running around and they said you
can play as those animals did you guys
get anything more solid out of this i
liked it because you ever played tail of
the sun on playstation one no i saw your
tweet about that and i looked it up and
i had no idea what's going on it is a
fantastic weird game and this just
reminds me of it in a lot of ways it's a
super weird game so great and this looks
like a next generation uh tail descent
so i think the the weird part was seeing
and cell come out and
like not be there with ubisoft and stuff
so i guess like
i don't know maybe did you track this
down at all apparently he is still with
ubisoft but also doing this separately
really i don't know like that's that was
the the talk that we got uh that that
came our way via twitter as this was
happening that i didn't actually go
verify but that just seems ridiculous at
some point it sounds like this is
strictly a side project for him it's
amazing that they would let him do that
maybe that was the the compromise of
just like look man we're never gonna let
you make beyond good and evil too why
don't you just stop
and he's like well i want to go make my
weird game about bow and arrow hunters
and you can play as a sheep
they're like a lady uh and they asked
him they said can you make it so you can
climb up towers to reveal more of the
world and he's like no he said well then
it can't be a ubisoft game
and then at that point he had to go out
on his own to make it so but then still
they're like we might still need you to
come in and like reinvent rayman to
everyone's life someone's gonna have to
do it again you know we've made two of
these we're keeping dibs on you right in
some way
uh super weird it's weird i mean there's
a tree there's a giant tree giant like a
big jet relating
any game that lets me play as an animal
i am way down with because i don't i
think video games you know have that
power to take us outside i would rather
have a tokyo jungle too really yeah you
want to play with animals those like
hollowed-eyed pomeranians like looking
at you from their dark souls those
things freak me out hey it was a rough
world man that's true
all right guys uh that's gamescom news
for today but of course gamescom is
running all week and it's a huge show so
we've got stories posted all the time
for that we've got a team over there uh
you guys doing any gamescom related
stuff no it's not that huge well tell us
like you're lying about it it's not they
already know the biggest they already
announced the sierra stuff like geometry
wars is coming but cake bread's not
involved so who cares every single day
we'll have breaking news
that you will not want to miss kano is
in mortal kombat
uh before i let you guys go uh can you
talk to us a little bit about the
shenanigans you're getting up to
tomorrow or is that a surprise no that's
a surprise no all right mom's the word
shenanigans ah but dan jeff thank you
guys for coming on chatting about call
of duty advanced warfare and gamescom
news now we're going to take a look at a
trailer for forza horizon 2 and we'll be
back with kevin van orde and risen 3.
car culture and festival culture are
both inherently social forza horizon 2
is inherently social so we ensure that
everyone's game feels connected even
when you're not playing multiplayer
there are lots of ways to see what your
friends are doing even in solo play your
friends are always connected to your
world
your friends driver tires explore the
open world with you even when they
aren't online you can challenge them to
street races or follow them to hidden
secrets in the world
rivals challenges and speed cameras
allow you to compete with your friends
asynchronously and at any point you can
pull up the map and see where your
friends are online and what they're
doing
when you decide to jump into online play
we ensure that transition is instant and
seamless and by removing lobbies the
waiting and all the hoops you have to
jump through players who don't usually
play online will find it really easy
entertaining and friendly
community is massively important to
forza and with clubs of up to a thousand
players you could create your own
community within horizon 2. what that
club is for though is entirely up to you
it could be a private club for you and
your close friends you could use it to
compete on the game's global club
leaderboards we've given you the tools
to create or find the perfect club for
you
we've got carmates which is a great
place to go and socialise chat and show
off your liveries or your tunes if
you're a really talented painter you can
enter a car meet and show off your
latest design
anyone else that's in there can take a
look and at the touch of a button
download your design for their own car
king and infected were two really
popular online game modes from the
original horizon in forza horizon 2 we
decided to build the perfect arenas from
the ground up
each one of these arenas is designed
with jumps and smashable items
everywhere taking full advantage of the
open world
we have two main ways to play online an
online road trip we'll take you on a
tour of the world from destination to
destination and then everyone in the
session will vote on where the road trip
goes next in online free roam it's
entirely up to you what you do you and
the people in your session can do
whatever you like start races play co-op
challenges hunt for secrets and
collectibles together or just cruise
around
there are no rules the world and
everything in it are yours to explore
together
this is an incredibly social game in
every sense we've reimagined what a
truly next-gen online experience should
be
you can play it however you want do
whatever you want
we'd like horizon 2 to be a game that
you play with friends
but maybe even a game in which you can
make new friends
i like it when
games with cars in them the trailers
have like a lot of music over them
because if it's just a lot of car noises
it just sounds like
us three sitting here going
i can't really do that
was good rob thanks kevin van orde
welcome to the set oh why thank you uh
we're gonna talk about the game you're
here to play in a second yeah but first
a reminder that we are running a ps4
giveaway here
hashtag greatestgaming moment you throw
that at us on twitter tell us what your
greatest gaming moment is and you'll be
entered to win a ps4 from us here at
gamespot and our friends at sony uh we
can take a look at some of these tweets
here what do we got do we have any
examples of greatest gaming moments
running wires from the upstairs to the
basement into an ethernet switch
yeah 16 player lan in halo on the yeah
i concur with that one rob is that your
twitter account that is my secret
twitter account i know you're not
eligible to win this you work for
gamespot it's not it's not happening i
paid completely beating tony hawk's pro
skater on my ps1 and one day with my
cousin and taking breaks to ice our
thumb joints that is intense yeah wow
have you ever uh
when i realized my 11th month daughter
would be a gamer one of her first words
was ratchet i'm an insomniac
what you don't like that i'm an
insomniac oh you don't like the pun yeah
all right fine in japan for ps2 launch
standing line for hours speak not like
of
japanese epic
nice all right keep those tweets coming
we'll be giving away the ps4 at the end
of the show uh kevin did you have any
did any of your greatest gaming moments
involve uh physical trauma that you had
to like ice any parts for no but i have
created physical trauma one of my
greatest gaming moments actually was
breaking a mr do arcade machine really
yeah so i used to steal quarters from my
mom okay so i would have been i don't
know how old i was maybe 12 or something
like that so i stole quarters from my
mother she had a big a big thing of
quarters and and i so i would just take
like a dollar here and there and then i
would go to the local convenience store
we had this community where they had
like a pool table and they had dig dug
and mr do
so i i used to love mr d well i love dig
dog tube i used to really love mr do so
i would go so one day i got so mad at
the game and we all know that i have
some rage issues when it comes to games
right there sometimes you don't want to
walk by kevin yeah yeah that's that's
right i can have i can have rage issues
with games so so 12 year old me this was
the beginning i
hammered with my fist the mr do uh dash
um and then it broke the joystick
and so i just left
i never told
the proprietor this was you were like
mom we have to move so she grabbed her
go bag and you guys were out of there so
i'm from a little town pennsylvania
called warren this was ron's variety
that it no longer exists so if you have
anything to do with ron's variety from
warren pennsylvania
really really sorry in advance if it was
that broken mystery machine that sunk
your business kevin is the man you're
going to want to see yeah but but yeah
i'm not here to tell you about those
stupid stories from the eighteen
hundreds you're here too i'm here to
play risen three yeah uh for you while i
well i spit forth all my my phlegm and
and saliva yes that's directed towards
rob he's got long sleeves and i know you
brought me on it's important to get uh
opinions from uh more bearded white
dudes and that's what i'm here to do yes
we covet your opinion oh bearded white
dude so this is
of course
the follow-up one
did you just teleport
and risen to a tricky guy
now this takes place in the same
um the same setting as risen to so you
go through
basically the same islands that you feel
like
yeah it is a pirate setting yeah and you
are
sort of a pirate but not anymore so you
do consort with pirates but you don't
necessarily have to be a pirate you
eventually have to side however with uh
one of the game's many factions um like
like four guys bad guys weird guys not
really bad guys they're all it's it's
really one of those things where you're
getting you're trying to band everybody
together to take on the giant you know
the the giant demons and stuff that are
that are overtaking the world you know
darkness has come and you actually your
character
is steel bird's sun steel beard being um
from from earlier in the series so
you're actually if you remember patty um
you're her
uh brother
so oops it's very easy to sometimes
speak to your companion so you can
always take a companion with you this
time so you've got bones i do have bones
but there are several um maybe in a bit
i'll go back to the ship
and uh show you who else i have
available this is maybe about halfway
through the game here um i finished on
on sunday
you conquered it i did conquer the game
on sunday i'm in the process of writing
review now
but uh it's it's interesting because
it's a lot like risen two but the combat
um has definitely been made more fluid
um the visuals are definitely much
better but the combat still has a lot of
problems um one of which is just how
exploitable it is
um that roll in particular the dodge mo
yeah you see is real
really
well you don't start that way that that
happened because i that is that that
happened because i took a specific i i
sided with a specific faction
right so so i'm a demon hunter here so
but you get to decide with the mages
with the pirates and so on and so forth
so
that teleport oh yeah picking up gold
pieces one by one that's my favorite
thing to do but even before you do that
um
your role i know what individual pieces
of gold really this isn't this doesn't
happen too much usually things are in
packs or you steal like oh that's fine a
bunch of gold and of course battles of
the last century
so when you find stuff like this a lot
of the time you end up uh
earning a new you know earning something
new like uh a new quest to go after or
sometimes you will learn about um
about uh treasure locations that way did
you just steal a clam from a dead goblin
totally
goblins always have claps and then what
you can do is see one of the great
things about clams is if if i have any
like i have shells like you can you have
46 clams you can and now we get to click
on them all to see how many might have
pearls
so i'm just clicking this is all you're
doing through yep
but you need those pearls like look so
all right i actually uh received and
here one of the reasons i was out here
is to get a shimmering pearl is that a
pile of clams it's just somebody looks
so you'd say for every 50 clams is one
pearl well no you can get a bunch of
pearls i needed that specific pearl
because she'd sent me after the pearl
so
at this stage though i am off to close
one of the things that you do in this
game is you have to close these portals
um that demons come through so that's
one of your having demons just coming
through all so right me and bones who is
a druid he's my favorite companion of
all of them um i i don't know exactly
how many there are there's like seven or
eight companions something like that
maybe it's only six but it's around that
um and uh he's my favorite the one of
the problems with companions is that a
lot of them
um kind of are the same like oops that
was already an open it's kind of they're
kind of boring so well not i like them
as personalities the problem is that
functionally
um a lot of them don't really do much
like different from the last we'll jump
down there yeah
i'm gonna come down here
and one thing that has returned from
risen is the nauseating way it handles
its camera when you're leaping
or falling um but anyway if you've
if you played risen then you which i
speak
wow you really are just legit just
dropping down this whole you do take
fall damage but
i'm not going down
far
is gravity reduced in the world of risen
you you just like i already have his
white tree
yeah well see the thing is you're also
you've lost your spirit so you can also
go into this kind of spirit mode to help
identify certain things but it's really
useless
um it's such a superfluous thing that
i'm not even sure why it was left in
but yeah so eventually bones will catch
up sometimes companions have a hard time
navigating
i have a hard time gently falling down
but and so now
to deal with some minions just a
reminder that if you guys have any
questions for kevin about risen three
we're taking a look in the twitch.tv
gamespot chat as well as the comments on
gamespot.com you can pass them along to
him and you can find out all about uh
what exactly a titan lord is kevin what
is a titanfall well
they're they're basically uh are they
titan lords are they giant versions of
humans that wear no clothes they're like
you know they're demigods basically in
this world okay
there's bones i'm just trying to get out
of the way because i wanted to
uncheck my weapon
and he's dead one of the uh
one of those moves another another you
know nauseating camera movement when you
when you get those finishing moves now
you can block
um now risen two when it was originally
released you couldn't dodge or block um
and it was some of the most frustrating
combat ever in the history you have to
like stand there and take it
yeah well there were there were ways
that you could try to deal with it but i
mean the combat in that sense is much
much improved it's much more fluid than
it used to be and it is the same world
but it's it's a lot different now um so
i mean they've really upped the visuals
in a lot of ways which is good um it's
still not looks like there's some neat
environmental design going on i like
those one guy on the wall
i mean it's not visually the most
attractive thing ever i mean there are
definitely much better looking rpgs out
there um but they really did clean up a
lot of stuff some of my favorite things
are in the in the character models when
you really get in close some of them
used to be really
so there's a teleport is that class uh
specific or is that something you just
picked up later on
oh that well it's it's not really a
teleport all it is is it's the dodge
with a new animation oh so it now has
the new animation you just don't see me
dodge anymore gotcha so it it
just don't see you at all yeah exactly
but it's functionally exactly the same
nice job you're going to steal all those
ghouls bones
yeah you can't always get bones one of
the most interesting things which is a
carryover is how leveling up works
um which is that you you do have like
your individual things that you can
level up like melee and ranged and
spirit and and magic and so forth but
you to to actually earn new skills you
still have to go buy them and those act
as thresholds to the things that you can
actually buy
so
you buy them with just currency you buy
them with currency buy them with bonus
you have to go to a trainer
and uh and spend gold on those so
oh
you're quick goblin
one interesting thing is is uh i mean
the game is a lot easier than rizzon and
rizen 2 ever were um
in the in the first two games it was
pretty easy to die from the very
beginning like just to one of those sand
devils on the beach it was like that
oops that tiny thing
just murdered me
um now like that kind of stuff isn't
bound to happen i don't know if i can
mine this or not nothing nothing so uh
nothing so shameful as being killed by a
tiny sand thing
yeah but now things have gotten a lot
easier the combat is is a lot more fluid
the downside of course is it's really
exploitable like you can just exploit
that rule to death if you're wondering
like why i'm not blocking yeah
that's one of the reasons because the
dodge
is so it's so powerful
that you you can
i mean the game is is compared to risen
and risen 2 which were much more
difficult this the combat in this game
eventually becomes a cakewalk
um so in that sense it's very different
until you get kind of the final boss
which is
really frustrating here's the lock
picking which is interesting in the
early times of the lock picking like you
can just i watched you pick a locker
when it's it was comical it was comical
because some when you only have four of
these things you just swipe it across
and back and you're done there's nothing
to it um but here like see i can't just
do that because that happens because you
actually have to do it in order
and you have to figure out what that
order is by playing a little bit so okay
that one stays up that one stays up that
one stays up so now the question is do i
go to the left or go do i go to the
right if i oh so that one's not the
right one to go to so you do this and
then this and then you still have to
make a decision which one i'll do that
oop not the right one so one two three
four back to this one and back to that
and that's all right that's how the lock
picking works but that is way more
interesting than what i saw you do when
you have any fewer than six um
of those then then
it's a one motion it's sort of a
meaningless lock picking system and even
then it's not too difficult believe it
or not two worlds two has my favorite
lock picking of all time um and nobody i
don't believe it nobody ever says
anything this guy two worlds yeah here's
a swamp golem so there are different
kinds of golems
um or golems depending on how you like
to pronounce it i don't want to upset
people how's it spelled oh i would say
golem for that for sure
rob
yeah
sure going for golem let's do it
let's do it let's we're going you know
what i should do some magic here i'll do
some magic just to say hey look i can do
some magic so
hope that didn't do anything that thing
is pretty cool looking i got some roses
i like some of the creature designs here
i like the environmental design is i
mean is exploration sort of a thing it's
the biggest thing actually here we'll
summon some fire from above
fire from above
although really he's just he's a
cakewalk you just kind of soared him to
death
now
when it comes to buying certain like
buying some of those skills like you
can't always just get
skin everything off of these creatures
every time like you have to earn the
ability to like get bones or skulls or
hides and things like that oh to salvage
to scavenge them off of the creatures
and what have you
see this is usually what lock picking is
like oh my god so in the early times
making that achievement progress well
the thing is i already i think i already
achieved i think i already have that
achievement maybe i'm playing offline
so it it's only going from where the i
was afraid that the game would update i
had it kept crashing on the other pc
which is i was afraid to update it in
case the press the the press build and
the
retail which came out today kevin is
this a game that is good would you
recommend this game i would say where's
your review status at i think that you
know what you're getting into when you
play a piranha bytes game so these are
the people that made gothic which is
still probably the you know maybe gothic
2 is the height of what they've done
um but you sort of know
what you're getting into you know that
you're going to get a a game with lots
of adventure and lots of stuff to do in
it and lots of cool places to go and
it's going to be wonky and weird and not
everything's gonna make sense and it's
gonna be clumsy and and maybe sometimes
a little bit broken and yet it's gonna
be kind of special because there are too
few games that do this and this game
does a lot of what it does really well
it just it it really is one of those
games it's like god i wish they could
have tightened up all the nuts and bolts
because uh it has a lot of loose nuts
and balls yeah but it's it's a really
satisfying game but holds itself
together and like you get you can find
some great enjoyment from playing it oh
totally and here's i don't have all of
the the companions here
um at this stage like i said i was about
this is your normandy this is your
normandy you don't start with this ship
eventually you only get a big ship once
you align and then all of your
companions join you
um so this is horus all right
just talk to horace i don't want to meet
all these people that's the same that's
fine
although well personalities are all are
all different it's just in combat
there's only one dude that kind of is
works differently he has a shotgun he's
uh he's one of the people from the
voodoo people
um that you get so it's like the same
kind of the similar races from risen to
all reappear but you do have new kinds
of magic that you could do like there
was no offensive magic in risen too
um now you can do all sorts of restoring
things that's crazy uh when is the rev
is the game out you said the game is out
today today yeah and review coming the
review should be either tonight or
tomorrow morning all right um so i'm
just in the process of writing it so be
on the lookout but i would say yeah if
you if you know
what reason is then go into it
all right yeah thank you kevin van orde
sure much appreciated that review will
be up on gamespot in the next day or so
folks be sure to keep an eye out for
that now we're gonna take a look at
fable legends and other land full of
cool environmental design uh with extra
chicken kicking and we'll be back with
surgeon simulator
oh the horror of surgeon simulator
let me tell you a story
of heroes
of four that came
four that fell
and of the heroes that took their place
bravely they fought
the future of albion in their hands
could it be that these heroes will
triumph
could it be they will vanquish all
let me tell you the story
of the villain
of how four heroes came
and four heroes were conquered
who
will take their place
who will save albion now
fable legends ladies and gentlemen i
didn't see a chicken kick there but i
was looking at mary kish desperately
trying to get the handle of surgeon
simulator hey mary kish
nurse waters yeah okay okay yes
i'm the intern
dr kish intern handlery uh we're here to
assist
you in the surgeon simulator video game
i'm really looking forward to this
innovative procedure where we're about
to perform today i'm really glad to have
both of you guys here with me
we're very talented and we're here for
you to uh help you mangle the poor heart
transplant that you're about to
undertake surgeon simulator been out on
pc for a while now like
great fun totally mad cap surgery
root brutality and weirdness yes yes is
that accurate pretty accurate the only
point in this game is to fail at surgery
and possibly learn from it
or just continue failing and learn that
you will never become a doctor ever in
your life yeah right i'm dr kish vorkian
okay
so you just kill people uh
i
now
do a surgery my hand may look a little
manly but it's only because
it's the watch it's really the watch
that makes your hand look i don't get
manicures very often because i'm too
busy saving lives
like this guy
activate
show us go to begin operation i'm
excited
should we begin this operation
presumably one of the buttons will do it
for you when
who is the doctor here
who is the doctor i ask you
it's like incomplete go to the tab go to
the tab on the side i got it you mean
call trisha yes
i forgot
to call her pills i need
there we go you know there are simulator
games that thank you
actively simulate things in like a real
serious way and then there are the
clumsy simulator games i got it and i
need you guys oh
can you imagine this like an actual
doctor's like not picking up his phone
are you drunk
spilling all his meds
all right okay now begin there it's the
tab
i've decided to begin the operation okay
i'm glad you decided to concur yes
let us proceed doctor i like that the um
time is blood running out of the
patient
touch his face touch his face real quick
give him a little
reassurance
you're going to be just fine buddy
i love you
he looks a little warm he looks a little
warm can we fan him off okay yeah
okay doctor whenever you're ready thank
you thank you um i'm a little sweaty can
i get a
can i get a towel please thank you oh
thank you
i believe
the first things first take off the
blood is to lower my hair sticks first
get some sprite in you you want to use
the triggers and such i could use oh oh
there you go he is okay
okay okay he's good starting he's good
ship shape okay doctor all right
what do you recommend
without lowering my hand
start the hammer
going to
grab this hammer
grabbing
so you can move your arm up and down can
i yes can i well so the motion appears
to affect your wrist
oh yeah you're pressing something there
why don't you just press all the buttons
okay and see what they do all my doctor
buttons press all your doctor buttons so
is this the music that doctors operate
to
listen you got to be intense obviously
someone here isn't a doctor again i feel
like this nurse taking care of he's
acting a little doctory
i'm i'm pretty sure it's the triggers
that help you go up and down is that
true
there oh
listen just a reminder doctor who's a
doctor here i feel like i'm sure that
you knew that i have a problem
yes
all right i need to focus
oh
okay
brilliant
good the cloth has already started to
slip off the patient just as we planned
i will the left side is exposed we're
gonna need to do a heart transplant here
now hey doctor so uh please go ahead and
uh crack
the rib cage we're going to need to get
to the heart right i love how you ever
so lightly touch the bone saw you know
just to give you a little bit of a few
tips here uh a delicate touch is really
all you need and then you just
gracefully
drop it
on the races
oh my gosh you spent all that time
picking it up doctor i can't help but
think that maybe i'll just do it myself
all right yeah just get in there with
the hand grab it just grab ahold of
those ribs best doctor in the state i
think that's going to you need to crack
the ribs before you can yank them out
there yeah hammer you wanted the hammer
to begin with there we go
just grab with your fingers there you go
now you've got it in the oh nope didn't
quite
here we go there we go oh god it's
coming down well the hammer's been lost
i will use this bottle
that hammer was defective oh you just
watched lost your watch the watch has
fallen out i'm so thirsty i cannot see
i don't need time
i need oh no i drugged myself
oh no
oh no doctor oh i feel like you really
need to do drugs doctor are you okay
i should have waited until after the
surgery will you get really messed up
just grab the drill already
doctor who's on the drugs here
is it you this is when i do my best work
doctor
i appreciate your dedication to losing
all of the tools
so that you can't harm the patient
but for the love of god
this operation
here we
go yep i see some blood it's happening
yes i'd start with a toothpick as well
a gentle scalpel to the ribs
poke some holes in the lungs to make
sure they can still breathe
do you even know
what we're supposed to be doing here
we're saving this man
i'm so high i think you should probably
grab the sword why don't you i see the
sword there's a song
okay
i concur
the saw is over by the patient as a
recall doctor oh do you have some blood
on your hands it's right by the
patient's face as you'll remember also
concur
we need a doctor in here for this doctor
bleeding
that's what you're here for nurse
now we're talking here we go
just please do not drop the saw
yes
you're sawing so well thank you you're
getting promoted
damn right
you are abrading those ribs uh very
thoroughly
i think you just knocked off that
rubbing it all around there we go oh i'm
seeing some breakage there oh this is
going broken up and down and up and down
and that's the way
did you learn that in med school yeah a
lot of times you learn the best when you
rhyme things
you crack their ribs
get inside their innards
mix them all up how long do the drugs
last
for a really long time i could use that
pencil write some of this down
right down
these notes
oh or yeah that's a good place for that
good place oh no we've lost it it's
really in there i don't know he's got
lead poisoning
i feel like you should take out some of
those ribs all right
let me just get your hand in there get
some organs out okay no the pencil is
always in there
the pencil was in there when i got there
ma'am i've made an astonishing discovery
get out
you've been living with a pencil
inside of you the whole time well
there's your problem right there
a pencil in them for some time
all right i'm gonna
oh yeah can you just bring that whole
device in there yeah if i could just
just clobber if i could just put more
items
i'm so high you are so high
you've definitely dosed yourself
something fierce scissors
yeah just make sure
we're trying to heart transplant here
right so you need to scissors if the
heart is still attached to the body you
can't transplant it i mean that is just
any scientist will agree
especially
medical scientist
stab him
and then
save his life
oh my god we got a bleeder we got a
bleeder clamp where's the clamp wow i'll
just leave those
just drink it here i have to use the cup
q-tips maybe you can soak it up with a
single q-tip let me get a q-tip
it's really hard
because i'm on so many drugs chevy shove
a q-tip in there
do you want to start this surgery again
doctor
and maybe not be so
this is calling it it's 10 11.
this is like the gonzo time of death
this is like the gonzo version i can't
pick up a q-tip i'm too high
nobody
the music is kind of hinting at your
highness as well but everything is a-oh
he is good to go at least we figured out
how to do that motion yeah oh look at
those other fingers yeah you got oh you
got a whole range of fingers
so you're controlling oh there's my fist
you're controlling the hand
my problem is not enough fist you should
give him drugs then maybe all the drugs
combined will even out
i think i already used all the drugs on
myself oh you did
i need just one cute let's start again
let's start again all right
restart the surgery time of second death
10 12.
restart let's uh let's try to get into
that rib cage a little more expediently
and get a lung out i want a single lung
yeah get a lung out all right are you
equal to the challenge i hope you're
paying attention
because one day you will become
the doctor not as good as you doctor i
know
oh yeah all right all right strong
starting really good about this
this is going to be grabbed the hammer
oh yeah look out
now just lower it down
oh nice powerful strike
good follow through
oh yeah there we go
work that wrist this is proper hammer
usage now we're talking
this is you're really getting a lot of
force behind it a lot of torque god just
pounding on the patient
over and over
oh no i'm not in his body
all right you got to get some of those
ribs free now
yeah yes keep going on that side let's
get
all those oh yeah now we're in business
oh yeah dr kid's working i think you
loosened up a longer process it's much
more successful than your last surgery i
feel like every surgery i learned before
flip the patient in the face oh oh my
goodness you know you can actually kill
them by doing that fail the surgery you
know this is very lifelike it is
possible to fail the surgery i don't
know if you folks at home
believe it all right what do i do now
i say you you know because you had some
of that head trauma just now i want to
use the drill and loosen up a little
little uh hole maybe go get some of the
blood coming out i think that's
reasonable
all right you better get that lung out
because i'm about to give away some
playstation fours
oh yeah like in like one minute we have
time we don't have time for that three
minutes
after three minutes of surgery time
i'm gonna be giving away a playstation 4
and if you do not have a lung out by
then
you oh my god doc doc oh god
oh god
listen
oh no oh no i lost my watch my watcher
that's the second one today oh no i
really liked that watch doctor you have
55 seconds remove the lung get the lung
out of that challenge okay okay
what do i need to get the lung out your
hand doctor oh
oh
oh no that's cool i need to get that
last rib
oh wait wait wait wait
oh no oh it's just sitting in there
oh it's still going oh wait i got it
i got it i got it you guys are making me
nervous
it's fine it works itself out it would
feel good
you have 20 seconds to grab that long
okay and get it out that was perfect i
think that long get your whole fist in
there and grab that long doctor okay
get it
about five seconds
oh she's got a hold of it three
two
one
it's coming oh we're into overtime i can
grant you a 10 second overtime i can
feel it cause you've got so pull pull up
just yank it out of there
oh
no is it because you got no i'm sorry
too many their heart is in the way
stupid heart that is not a heart oh
you're a doctor mary congratulations
saved good job surgeon simulator now
available on playstation 4
so that you can make horrible doctor
situations in your own living room i
can't believe
that we saved a life we saved them he's
got one log now and uh real and jacked
up
blood loss rate all right so
your greatest gaming moments you've been
tweeting them at gamespot all week and
we have gone through them all there are
many great ones uh i like the ones that
sort of invoke the specific game like
riding into mexico for the first time in
red dead redemption the ones that invoke
uh the connections that these games can
form with children and stuff like that
those are really cool but the ultimate
winner of game spots uh
and sony's playstation 4 giveaway
is powdered doughnut 69 aka ryan on
twitter for this tweet
playing rock band 2 on drums to
eventually become involved in playing
real drums
love the connection of the video gaming
to the real life drumming and ryan you
just won yourself playstation 4. hooray
you're a winner
uh so ryan will be getting in touch with
you about how to get your playstation 4
and uh we will be expecting some uh some
tweets about you know the games you're
gonna play oh look at how excited you
are
what kind of dance moves you teach it uh
with the box life saving box i want one
looks real hot but i want to thank all
you folks who submitted and remind you
that you can still win a playstation 4
from sony if you go to
greatnessawaits.com and make a mural
there just upload a picture of your face
pick a few uh
game characters to join you in your
mural to create
your mural say mural a few more times
but go ahead and enter
greatnessawaits.com and you can win a
playstation 4 there's still a chance can
you be a surgeon in the mural
no lighter than i thought which is
fitting because you can't be a surgeon
in real life either mary kish
and rob handlery thank you both for
coming on oh it's been a pledge this man
needs a doctor his appendix is about to
burst
oh god
please go to my iso we do not need to
watch what's going on over here
crack rob's ribs thanks you guys for
watching the lobby today be sure to stay
tuned to game spot for all sorts of
gamescom news this week as well as an
exciting event on thursday morning from
blizzard and the new expansion to world
of warcraft warlords of draenor i'm your
host chris waters saying thanks for
watching and we'll see you next week
adios
goodbye
you're you're a crazy murderer that was
so so weird
you